French is the sexiest language ooh ooh
oh I strongly agree strongly agree I
strongly agree that French is the
sexiest language I'm going to hit an
oval okay interesting I'm going to hit
an oval right
here because on some days it's French
but other days I like Italian oh do you
yeah I think Italian's super sexy
Italian I think Italian's super sexy
what do you like about the Italian
accent I just think it's smooth he
speaks the French by the way who's seen
you know his ke peel fren waiter sketch
have you SE that
sketch would you care
for the up thing as a French person is
it
sounds it sound real it sounds real but
as a French speaker do do you feel it
sexy somewhere in the middle somewhere
somewhere in the middle whereas when I
hear Italian I'm like you know
damn